pft live we asked for odds for teddy
bridgewater's next destination and
points bet delivered there they are
now i'll say this carolina plus 150 i'm
not taking that action i don't want any
part of that because i don't think he's
going to play for carolina he's got 17
million in salary this year 10 million
of it is guaranteed i think he's gone
before week one and if they have to cut
him they'll cut him they're not paying
him 17 million dollars he's not going to
take a pay cut to be back up to sam
darnold denver i think makes sense other
teams not on the board 49ers seahawks
they make sense as well buccaneers makes
sense if he's cut and the buccaneers
then sign would be tom brady's backup i
know there's a report the bucks aren't
interested i just think that's part of
the dance
to make sure the panthers don't think
they're going to get something in return
for teddy bridgewater miles we put that
up there because our draft today and we
only have time for one pick each
trades that we think will slash should
slash could happen over the course of
the next three weeks as the draft
approaches with specific terms to which
you will be held
oh boy man that means i got to be really
specific all right well i'll take a team
that was actually on that graphic for
teddy bridgewater but i don't think that
they're going to trade for teddy
bridgewater at least in this scenario i
think that the broncos are going to go
up to number four overall they're going
to trade number nine this year a 2022
first round pick and a 2022 third round
pick and they'll select justin fields
i'm just not convinced that they want to
ride with drew locke i think that they
have a new gm and george payton he's
probably going to want to come in and
select his own qb and then down the road
next year who knows what they're going
to do with head coach but i like the way
justin fields plays i think we all
figure what the quarterbacks are going
to be at one two and three after mack
jones goes to san francisco justin
fields still available broncos trade up
they get their quarterback of the future
mike
now and thank you very much for that i i
think that the broncos are in play for a
trade i don't think it's going to be a
trade-up to get justin fields i think
the price is going to be too high you
look at what the dolphins got from the
49ers the 49ers go from 12 to 39 to four
and i just i think it's too much i think
it's not going to happen for that reason
i think what will happen is teddy
bridgewater to the broncos with
bridgewater reducing his salary from 17
to 12
with the panthers paying let's say 3
million of the 10 million fully
guaranteed so the total outlay for the
broncos is 9 million and in return they
give up a fifth round pick for teddy
bridgewater and possibly a conditional
pick next year based upon the number of
starts teddy bridgewater has maybe a six
next year conditional six if he starts
eight or more games i know that's
ridiculously specific but i think that's
what's going to happen because george
payton the gm in denver
was in minnesota when they drafted teddy
bridgewater they loved teddy bridgewater
he never got a chance to become what he
could have been with the vikings because
of that freak torn acl they love him
still in minnesota and peyton's got a
chance now to add him to a quarterback
room that has drew lock and it's
short-term insurance against lock not
getting it done it removes the urgency
to try to trade up and then you don't
have to sit and wait and hope that maybe
someone falls to you at nine now i'll
say this maybe what the broncos do
is sit tight at nine
see what happens
and if a guy doesn't fall to them or if
maybe they can't do a deal with the
falcons or the bengals or the dolphins
to jump up and get a fields for a
reasonable amount
then after round one they do that deal
with the carolina panthers and get teddy
bridgewater assuming he's still
available but i think he will be and i
think that his destination will be the
denver broncos that's our one pick each
draft of the trades that we think should
happen as the draft approaches or during
the draft itself
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports